KEVIN: Next, I've got
Walter Isaacson is
going to moderate a really
great session on innovation
in education.
And certainly Walter doesn't
need much introduction, either.
He's the chairman, and
president, and CEO,
of the Aspen Institute.
He's been the CEO of CNN, and
the editor of Time Magazine.
He's also a
bestselling biographer.
So please help me
welcome Walter.
WALTER: Thank you.
Thank you, Kevin.
Well, our session right
now is on something
that keeps coming up in
our conversation, which
is education and how
innovation in technology
are going to transform it.
I think it's a useful topic.
If Ben Franklin came back today
and walked into a classroom,
he'd say, "Oh, yeah.
That's exactly how we did it.
That's exactly what we made.
The teacher stands there
and gives a little lecture,
and 24 kids are sitting around."
It's the one major
sector of our lives
that has not been
totally transformed
by the digital revolution.
And I think we're at
an inflection point.
It's about to happen, whether
it's MIT and Harvard joining up
for edX the way Stanford has
already been doing for higher
education, or what's happening
in the K through 12 classroom.
Starting with you,
Bill, you've written
about four or five things that
are going to be transformative,
but let me start with the
first one you talk about,
which is re-imagining textbooks.
How do you think that's going
to change, and make personalized
education?
BILL: Well, if you get pervasive
digital devices, very cheap
tablets, and pervasive
internet connection,
then one can imagine eliminating
the paper-based textbook.
And an interactive textbook
is a very different thing.
In fact, the boundary
between quiz,
lecture, textbook, is
basically eviscerated.
You can track the
student, bring in a video,
ask him a few questions
to keep them engaged.
And the invention of
what that multimedia
educational thing called
the future textbook,
but it's really all those
things brought together.
We're in the process of figuring
out what that is right now.
And there's a lot of
innovators-- for profit,
and nonprofit innovators--
who are participating in that.
WALTER: I was at
Sci and Math Academy
in our hometown of New Orleans,
which Sal and I come from, run
by some Teacher
America Corps members.
And there are no textbooks.
They just have curriculum.
And the teachers up there
on a dashboard saying,
oh, these two students
don't understand
that x and y are different.
And these two--
how do you-- do you
think there'll be just a totally
disruptive transformation
of how we do curricula?
Or do you think
textbooks will then just
be put in digital form?
BILL: Well, we want to be a
little conservative about this,
because in a sense, every time
something new comes along,
they say education will change.
Textbooks came along and
anybody could read them.
We got TV sets.
We got videotape.
We got computer-aided
instruction.
And so far technology-- at
least in the classroom--
has had absolutely no effect.
So the issues of motivation--
why should I learn this?
Am I the person
who's good at this?
There's so much complex human
motivation in the learning
process that to say
that just to mechanize
the pieces-- like, OK,
just click on the lecture,
we don't need the lecturer-- the
actual usage of things like MIT
OpenCourseWare is mind-blowing
for one reason-- basically
nobody uses it.
I mean, take the very best
Walter Lewin physics course,
which is the third one up there.
About 3,000 people have
gone through the thing.
And it's free.
It's fantastic.
I love the guy.
But there's no market for
people at home at night
saying "Oh, yeah, how do
those wave equations work?"
Without a job or a degree,
so far this whole hey,
it's online, therefore it will
be utterly different-- there's
been as many failures
as successes.
Now I think some of the stuff
that Sal and Bror are involved
in are going to be
amazingly successful.
So I do think this
time, this is different.
WALTER: So everybody talked
about flipping the classroom,
and you are the ones who've
been successful at that so far.
Explain how you think
that's going to work.
SAL: Yeah, you know, when
you go to this reality,
and it's been happening already.
I mean, for us it's been kind
of an inadvertent adventure,
but you have this reality where
students are going to a place,
and they're learning from
videos and exercises,
and getting feedback-- you
start to realize, well, OK.
They can all learn at
their own pace now.
And as soon as you make
that one assumption--
that every student can learn
at their own pace, master
concepts, and move on, and
kind of build a scaffold--
it actually allows
you to rethink
every aspect of the
education system.
You no longer have to group
kids by age-based cohorts.
You no longer have
to have a teacher
the front of the room
giving a lecture.
You no longer have to
have all the desks pointed
in the same direction.
You no longer have to
have teachers separate
from each other.
You know, I have 20 students.
You have 20 students.
And we have no peer interaction.
And so what we're seeing is--
and we started off as kind
of a virtual thing for
anybody out there to learn--
WALTER: Actually,
will you explain
the story of how
you got started?
That's near to my heart.
AL: Oh, yeah, New Orleans
connection-- you know,
right after I got married,
family from New Orleans
was visiting me in Boston.
I'm now in northern California.
And 12-year-old cousin Nadia
having trouble with math.
And I offered to tutor her.
And a little-- about
two years into it,
word got around in the family.
And I was tutoring
about 15 cousins.
And then famously, a
friend said-- well,
I was having trouble
scaling myself.
I had a day job.
And he said why don't you
stick some lessons on YouTube?
I said, "No, that's for cats
playing piano, not real math."
But then I gave it a shot,
and famously, my cousins
told me they like me better
on YouTube than in person.
And so I kept going.
And so the YouTube videos,
there's a ton of them now.
There are six million kids
using it every month now.
We're a team of 30 people now.
But yeah.
So when we launched
kind of in a big way,
and we started building
our organization,
we assumed this is just a
supplemental thing out for kids
anywhere to learn, or
adult learners, too.
But then some school
districts said
no, this is interesting to us.
This is kind of different--
true differentiated instruction.
This could be a game changer.
WALTER: And tell us what school
districts have adopted it.
And give me an example
of how that's worked
AL: Yeah.
So the most famous is Los
Altos in Silicon Valley.
They're now district wide,
but it's been a KIPP prep,
Summit prep, a couple of other
charter schools in Oakland.
I think the one that's actually
pushed the envelope the most is
Marlborough School in Los
Angeles, which is really
an elite girl's school.
And what they did is they
said, yeah, no reason for it--
we have to do this
Prussian model
where all students
learn at the same pace.
And we're going to have a
seventh through 12th grade
girls all in the same classroom,
all learning at their own pace.
And if you visit one
of these classrooms,
there's a ton of peer
to peer interaction.
And what the teacher's doing--
they're no longer the lecturer.
They're doing one
on one interactions.
It's made the classroom more
of an interactive, or human
experience.
WALTER: Bror, what have you
learned about how people learn,
and how does that get applied?
And maybe even do
it, if you would,
in an international context.
So many people here are
from around the world.
What have you learned
from around the world
of how different
people learn things?
And especially in your higher
education and career training
things at Kaplan--
tell us how that works.
BROR: What's great
about working now
at this intersection between
education, technology,
and actually learning science
is that all of these things
are now ready to go, ready
to get something really done.
And on the learning science
side, a lot of the things Sal
is describing actually
back up exactly what's
being found when you
look experimentally
at how people actually learn.
And there's been a lot of
that work over the last 20, 30
years-- things like giving
people control over their pace.
And that turns out to
help all learners, novices
and expert learners.
Things about using media
together with a voice over,
and that's exactly how
Sal Khan's videos work.
He doesn't show his face.
He's actually showing a key--
write it as he's doing it.
So your eye is tracking what
he's actually talking about.
That turns out to line up with a
bunch of the research about how
you should use media--
things about using
simple, informal language,
things about technology-- that
allow you to take a really
good learning solution.
Because the best tutors do
these kinds of things, too.
What technology
lets you do is take
a good solution-- or
actually a bad solution--
and make it affordable,
reliable, available, and data
rich.
So all of those things now
become possible for us to do.
And it's possible for us
to do around the globe.
The materials that you create
that are introductory materials
and demonstration
materials can suddenly
become available to
everyone around the globe.
And then you have local
folks who get together
to provide that next
stage of feedback,
and counseling, and
answering questions
that the online materials
don't actually describe.
And that local
work can also then
become culturally more connected
to where you are, and give
examples where that
is happening as well.
It gives a terrific opportunity
to make the whole process much
more efficient around
time and effort.
And what it actually does--
and this is a little bit odd--
but it begins to drag education
into the modern economy,
where to do all
this, you actually
have to spend a lot
more effort up front.
This is not typically somebody
sitting down the night before
and doing a whole course.
It becomes well, let's look
at the learning science.
Let's think about
our objectives.
Let's structure this thing.
Let's figure out where
do the interactives go.
When do we need a
person to engage?
When do we use the
automated systems?
That can be a lot.
You build all that.
But now your variable costs
come down, potentially,
because you're using teachers,
well-trained human beings,
in a system for what
they're really good at.
And allow the machines,
and the tools,
and the media to be designed
to do the rest really well.
So at kaplan, as a business
doing this kind of work,
we're trying very hard
now to actually use
large scale-- we have more
than a million learners--
to begin to generate data, to do
experiments along these lines,
just as Sal is doing-- to
see if we apply this learning
science now at scale, as a
learning engineering exercise,
can we get those benefits?
And then can we keep
going, and scale,
and transform how we
do all our education?
It's a very exciting
time to be doing.
WALTER: Sal, what
Bror just described
is really how a for-profit
model can work well,
because it can do the
upfront cost, do it to scale.
Yours is a non-profit model.
Then we have the model,
the Harvard-MIT doing edX,
and Stanford doing two different
things, whatever it may be.
How do you see the mix of
profits and non-profits,
and what's the advantages
of each in this?
SAL: Yeah, I think
it's all great.
I think we really are in
kind of a Renaissance.
I mean, every week we're hearing
a new-- I mean, Harvard, MIT,
these are not
small institutions.
This is, I think it was
the biggest announcement--
WALTER: You have four degrees
from amongst them, right?
SAL: Yes.
So I'm making sure
that they'll never--
WALTER: And Bill never got
one, as far as I can remember.
[INAUDIBLE] got an honorary--
SAL: He's is getting a
higher return on his.
[LAUGHTER]
I think it's all great.
It's all innovation.
I think everyone is seeing
what works in certain contexts.
And saying that we
should do that, too.
We should do that.
Our thought, or my
thought process-- and it
was really kind of
delusional, when I literally
was operating out of a
closet for several years--
it was that we are kind
of at this inflection
point in history.
We've been talking about
it this whole session.
And I felt that any
inflection point in history
needs new institutions.
And it wasn't obvious that
new institutions to this point
had actually percolated up.
New companies had, but
not new institutions.
And so in my delusional-- I
read a lot of science fiction
books-- I was,
like, maybe I could
be like Hari Seldon
in the Foundation.
This could-- we read the
same books, obviously.
But they're--
BILL: People who read The
Foundation are in the vanguard.
SAL: Yes, Isaac Asimov.
But I mean, it was crazy,
and kind of idealistic
on one aspect.
But on another aspect, it's
completely practical now.
Maybe we could do
civilization-scale education.
We can make it free.
We can make it an institution.
I mean, this content
I was talking about,
if Newton had made videos on
calculus, I wouldn't have to.
This stuff is evergreen.
It's not changing.
BILL: His notation
was a little--
SAL: Yeah, he was
a little eccentric.
BILL: Leibniz will do.
SAL: Yeah, Leibniz
might have been, yeah.
But so this stuff is evergreen.
This stuff is going
to-- these videos
could be teaching-- not
just videos, interactions,
questions, simulations,
they could teach kids
500 years from now.
And so it just seemed like
too crazy of an opportunity
to try to-- I mean, there's
nothing wrong with it
as a business, but maybe
it could be an institution.
That was the thinking for us.
WALTER: Bill, how
does that change
the role of the teachers, and
help you scale good teachers?
BILL: Well, what we'd
really like to know
is why is it so hard to get kids
motivated around these things?
I mean, after all, it's
really in the kids' interest
to get a high school degree
and get a college degree.
It's not just that
you make more money.
You meet more
interesting people.
Everything is better
about that path in life.
And so our failure to convince
them to help themselves
in that way, it's
very disappointing.
And the US statistics
are horrific.
We doubled what we put into
education over the last 20
years.
And our output did
not improve at all.
And other countries,
on the other hand,
have done very, very well.
So as for younger
students, there's
going to be a structured
environment where a teacher is
there supervising
them quite a bit.
One of the most interesting
things-- at a conference
Sal and I went to, we
heard about a thing
called an alliance
school, which is a charter
school in California,
which in the US
is where most of the good
experimentation takes place.
They have a class
of 48, but when
they ask the kids what
they liked about the class,
they said, oh, it's
so small and personal.
Well, it's because they have
16 with the teacher, 16 doing
peer education-- and peer
education, where you have kids
help other kids, that
is a coming thing.
And figuring out how to
technologically help those kids
group together, make that
work, that is super powerful.
It's also very cheap.
And then they have
a final group of 16,
where they're just looking
at Khan Academy type content,
playing some of the
math game things.
And so you do math by
rotating through the three
different experiences.
And their results are way
better than a class of 25
done the normal way.
WALTER: You just said that
most of the experimentation,
innovation being done is from
some of the innovative charter
schools in the country.
In New Orleans now, almost every
kid goes to a charter school.
And the parents have choice.
It's almost a
voucher system where
the money follows the student.
So you have competition, where
a KIPP and a YES and whatever
do it-- why shouldn't
that be the model, as it
is with higher education,
where there's competition
and people have choice.
Why should that be the model
to drive innovation in K
through 12?
BILL: Well, it's not like
higher ed is fantastic.
The dropout rates
in US universities
are higher than
any other country.
Their costs have also
gone up, actually
more than a factor of
two in the last 20 years.
And the output has not
improved all that much.
So there's pathologies
there as well.
The uniform, sort of monolithic,
state by state approach
that we have-- yes, that
probably holds things back.
But politically to get that
to change is very hard.
I mean, charter schools--
California shorts their charter
schools in a way
that most of them
are financially
unstable right now.
And the union often are
used for the status quo,
whether it's against charters
or against personnel systems.
So it's very, very
tough, because everybody
wants a minimum standard.
And using a
market-based approach,
you worry that you
won't hit that minimum.
And so you get this
kind of rigid approach
as the acceptable.
WALTER: But is that good or bad?
BILL: Well, I don't know how
to-- it's very hard to change.
There are countries that
do this better than we do.
And you hope that we
could learn from them.
So you have-- can we learn
how to do personnel systems?
And then can you
bring technology in?
Those are the two
things that should
make you optimistic
about education--
that people like Kaplan
are on a for-profit basis,
and things like Khan Academy
really are going to catch on.
But the institutions will be
slow to recognize these things.
Thank goodness for charters
and some young teachers
who are willing to
essentially break the rules.
WALTER: Bror, why do you think
the profit model will succeed
in a world where so many people
are now doing this for free?
BROR: It's a great question.
Part of it is because,
as we just talked about,
technology is not
the only answer.
It doesn't actually solve all
of the human training needs.
The human mind is built
to take a lot of feedback,
a lot of customized feedback,
and to use that very well.
There are some things
that you can automate.
And over time, there will
be more and more things.
But at the end of
the day, if you're
trying to write a
persuasive essay,
you need somebody
to give you feedback
on why it's not persuasive,
and how to do it again.
And then to look and see did you
get it right this time or not?
Another aspect of
this, why I think
there's real value that
people will pay for,
is connecting the
outcomes of education
itself to the outcomes
that are needed,
let's say in the workplace.
So a lot of our work is in
the higher education space,
so folks go from
us to the workplace
to many of your
businesses, perhaps.
And one of the missing
things in higher education
is a very clear link
between how people
are doing in their first
six months of work.
And shouldn't that
be a feedback loop
that comes back to the training
environments, or the learning
environments, to modify those?
And from Doctor Kahneman's
work last night, discussion
last night, one of the
fundamental barriers
is the system one,
system two problem,
which is that experts--
more than half of what
is human expertise in an
expert's mind is subconscious.
That is, when they
teach a novice,
as you do, you stick
an expert up in front
and have them teach.
They will tell a
novice less than 30%
of what the novice needs
to know to execute.
It's why your first year
in any job is an agony.
It's because all of the
experts before you ended up not
telling you more than
30% of what you needed
to know the first
day on your job.
There are techniques--
and we're experimenting
with those at Kaplan-- that
come out of cognitive science.
And I've talked with some
of you about those things.
It's called cognitive
task analysis,
where you identify with
objective measures-- out
of 1,000 people
in your workforce,
who are the three that
you want to clone?
Who are the three who
are making decisions
that are amazing for your
business in their role?
And then you can do an interview
process to get more like 70%
of that.
And then create training
materials, and methods,
and practice that targets those
skills, put those in place,
and begin the
feedback loop on it.
With an objective reason, you
can make it clear, transparent,
what you're trying
to do and why.
And that allows you to
change it over time, too.
As the job role changes, you
keep interviewing new experts
and you make adjustments.
Well, now, that takes real
work, and repeated work.
It's also enormously valuable
for both you as employers
and for the employees,
to now sign on and know
that the training
track is leading
to high-quality
expertise that's been
validated in the workplace.
So to me what's happening
now-- and it's terrific--
is the free solutions are
providing an increasing
baseline of learning
materials, right?
You can't get away with
poorly designed lectures,
and then ignore the students.
It's just no, that's not
going to work any more.
There's all these
great free materials
to provide a baseline.
And then above that, that's
where it gets exciting.
What comes after that?
What feedback do you do?
How do you design
outcomes to improve
on what's available that's free?
And I think it'll be, just
like always in technology,
an ever increasing
race that way.
And so I think that's part of
what's exciting about that.
WALTER: Sal, you can
remember your days
at MIT and at Harvard.
Khan Academy has
no such campuses.
Kaplan has places
where people go,
but they aren't quite
campuses like that.
What is the role, if any,
that actual, physical campuses
with human interaction
should and will play?
SAL: I think it's
a huge role, and I
think the important
part is what you just
said-- the human interaction.
And the problem is if you go
to most campuses right now,
yeah, we're all
in the same room,
but there's actually very
little human interaction.
I mean, I used to sit in
300-person lecture halls
the whole semester.
I didn't know the professor.
I might have known two people in
the classroom-- no interaction.
WALTER: By the way, every
professor who taught you
claims that they know you well.
SAL: Yeah, they saw potential.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah, I met a couple of them.
WALTER: More people taught Bill
Computer Science at Harvard
than even ever taught there.
Yeah.
SAL: But so what
I say, I imagine
school for my own children.
I imagine a highly
interactive environment.
And so what we think is--
education's a spectrum.
At this end is your
multiplication,
facts, and vocabulary.
And then out here is building
a robot, starting a business,
painting a picture--
I mean, really
open-ended, creative things.
And what we see as the
role of technology is-- OK,
we're already doing this part.
And we're going to keep
pushing the envelope.
We'll use data
and we'll, make it
better and better and better.
And we'll iterate on it.
And we'll connect it to real,
economic, valuable things.
And then as we do this,
there's kind of some fear
that I-- is this is going
to-- because right now, this
is where school is focused.
Is this going to replace
the teachers there?
Is it going to turn them
into monitors of some kind?
No, no, this is an opportunity
to move the humans over here,
where the humans are good.
WALTER: Bill, what do you
think the role of things
like social networks and gaming
are in transforming education?
BILL: Well, it's
fascinating that one
of the educational
start-ups, this one Grockit,
has the ability to do SAT
testing, all these things.
And you can do the
quizzes on your own,
or you can do them
with a group of people.
And overwhelmingly-- over 90%--
people choose to do it almost
as a contest, where if somebody
is slow, then you can say,
wow--
WALTER: On a social
network, you mean?
BILL: Well, it's online,
multiple people interacting.
The word social network--
WALTER: But I mean
it's not place based.
BILL: No, its online.
Exactly.
No, it's a $10 a month
thing, where you sign up
and you have access.
And you can do
solo tests, or you
could go into this sort
of gaming-like thing.
Now the gaming
thing, some people
really take it where they design
a very rich, interactive game.
Manga High's a
for-profit that's done
a pretty strong set
of games for math.
Our foundation is funding a lot
of people, like Zoran Popovic
over at UW and others, to
do some rich games that
have a way of engaging you
in some mathematical things
that you may not even
realize that you're learning.
So there's a lot
of promise there.
Gaming and
simulation, hopefully,
can make the subject more
approachable, more interesting,
more hands on.
WALTER: Kaya
Henderson was walking
the hall-- the chancellor of
the Washington, DC schools--
and was explaining that
with gaming, there's
something odd, which is that the
boys take to it, because it's
a real competition.
And they will stay up all
night to beat their friends
and get more points, and
suddenly be 50 points ahead.
But-- and I don't want to just
make it a gender-based thing,
but different people
learn differently.
And that gaming, in some ways,
turns some other people off.
Do you see that?
SAL: We do see that.
Actually, I mean,
the first complaint
when the Los Altos
pilot started, was there
was a subset of boys who got
addicted to it, literally.
Like they couldn't-- it was
a good addiction, I guess.
But they were learning math,
but they were-- just couldn't
get them-- their
parents couldn't
get them to focus
on anything else.
WALTER: Gee, what a problem.
SAL: Yeah, no.
There are worse things.
But what we did see
is there are also
ways to motivate girls
with game mechanics.
And it's not-- obviously,
it's a distribution.
And we have seen that girls are
more focused on achievement,
more focused on what
they've done, more
focused on their
portfolio of actions,
while boys are more
focused on points.
And maybe we don't outgrow
it, for some of us.
WALTER: Speaking of people
who haven't outgrown it,
let me open it up for questions.
Please.
If we can turn up the lights,
and raise some hands, and get
started.
BROR: One thing I might say
about the gaming side, which
is it is actually very
interesting, because the risk
is some of the gaming
elements can wind up
being more distracting
than helpful.
But once you get
an initial mastery,
then the gaming elements
provide that encouragement
for repeated practice,
which is what's
needed to build a lot of
fluency and familiarity,
so that the skills
begin to be embedded.
So there's this
careful trade-off
between when you're initially
instructing, and trying
to get ideas across, the
very first examples you show,
and then practice environments
that are exciting and engaging.
WALTER: And you've written
about that mastering that
comes from-- it's something
we sometimes miss.
BROR: Yes, exactly.
WALTER: In the traditional
education structure,
we lecture and then we test.
But we don't give
that-- and games
can do that, you're saying.
BROR: Yes, games can do that.
But so can simple things
like worked examples,
where you go from talking
about what you need to do.
Then you give a demonstration.
It turns out demonstrations
are enormously important.
Show somebody doing
what you said.
And then you do what's
called a work example, where
you give people partially
filled out work.
And so you do a piece, they
do a piece, you do a piece,
they do a piece.
It's exactly what the
best tutors actually do.
But the technology
now allows you
to take what is
a very effective,
an expensive learning
technique, and turn it
into something that can
be distributed en masse.
And that gives you
then that experience,
and builds the mastery
and confidence.
And it turns out it
shrinks learning time,
and increases the
amount of mastery.
It's fascinating.
WALTER: And you should read his
blog, by the way, Number One.